Fachleute der NASA und des Deutschen Zentrums
für Luft- und Raumfahrt (DLR) starten einen
neuen Versuch, den Maulwurf der Marssonde
Insight wieder in Gang zu bekommen.
Kurz nach dem Start war er stecken geblieben.
Clixoom Science & Fiction - hier gibt es täglich
spannende Science-Videos, abonniert den Kanal
und aktiviert die Glocke nur dann verpasst
ihr nichts.
Los geht’s!
Herzlich willkommen!
Hier bei Clixoom Science & Fiction halten
wir Euch regelmäßig über die neuesten Entwicklungen
bezüglich der NASA-Mission “Mars InSight”
auf den Laufenden.
Und das ist wirklich spannender als jeder
Thriller.
Ende Februar diesen Jahres (2019) ging der
Bohrer der Mars-Sonde “InSight” an den
Start, doch schon nach rund vier Stunden musste
er kapitulieren.
4.000 Hammerschläge waren es bis dahin, doch
plötzlich ging gar nichts mehr und der Maulwurf
kippte seitlich um 15 Grad.
Und seitdem tritt die NASA mit dem Experiment
HP3 (“Heat Flow and Physical Properties
Package”) quasi auf der Stelle.
Die Fachleute sind frustriert.
Hatten sie doch große Hoffnungen in dieses
Experiment gesteckt.
Allen voran natürlich die Fachleute des Jet
Propulsion Laboratory der Nasa und des Deutschen
Zentrums für Luft- und Raumfahrt (DLR).
Denn ihr Plan ist gigantisch: Die Rammsonde
sollte sich bis zu fünf Meter Tiefe in den
Marsboden graben, um dann den Wärmefluss
aus dem Inneren des Roten Planeten detailliert
zu erkunden.
Ermöglicht wird das durch die Kombination
aus Bohrhammer und eines Temperatursensors,
durch den neben der Wärmeverteilung auch
die Beschaffenheit des Mars-Inneren analysiert
werden kann.
Oder besser gesagt: KÖNNTE.
Denn der Maulwurf sitzt fest und alle bisherigen
Versuche, ihn aus seiner misslichen Lage zu
befreien, sind gescheitert.
Jetzt ist ein neuer Anlauf geplant, dem Maulwurf
doch wieder ans Graben zu bringen, damit er
letztendlich dann doch die geplante Tiefe
erreicht.
Lange Zeit hatten die Experten analysiert,
warum genau der Maulwurf feststeckt.
Seit Juni (2019) ist die Ursache des Problems
aber klar.
Denn der Roboterarm hatte das Gehäuse des
Bohrers angehoben und offenbart, dass es der
Rammsonde wohl an seitlicher Reibung fehlte.
Dazu der DLR-Forscher Tilman Spohn: “Bei
einer Tiefe von 35 Zentimetern hatte der Maulwurf
die Führungsfedern des Gehäuses verlassen
und sich dann aufgrund unzureichender Bodenreibung
im Kreis gedreht, ohne weiter vorzudringen.
(...) Es zeigte sich, dass offenbar eine feste
Kruste von etwa zehn Zentimetern zementierten
Sands über recht lockerem Sand liegt“.
Im Sommer versuchten die Experten deswegen
also das Loch um den Mars-Maulwurf einzudrücken.
Doch diese Versuche mit der flachen Schaufel
und deren spitzen Seite misslangen.
Die Wissenschaftlerinnen und Wissenschaftler
mussten enttäuscht feststellen, dass die
Kruste wohl zu hart und widerstandsfähig
ist.
Bei dem neuen Anlauf, der in einigen Wochen
starten soll, muss also anders vorgegangen
werden.
Geplant ist es, mit Hilfe der Schaufel des
Roboterarms Druck von der Seite auf den Mars-Maulwurf
auszuüben.
Und zwar währenddessen dieser anfängt, wieder
zu bohren.
Die Fachleute erhoffen sich, dass dieser Gegendruck
ausreicht, um den Bohrer tiefer in den Untergrund
eindringen zu lassen.
Diese Taktik wird auch als “Pinning” bezeichnet.
Das Problem: Dieser Plan kann nicht vorab
auf der Erde ausprobiert werden, da der Boden
des Mars’ nicht einfach so repliziert werden
kann.
Dazu Tilman Spohn: “Wir wissen nur so viel
über den Boden, wie uns die Bilder zeigen".
Zunächst muss der Mars-Maulwurf wieder zum
Leben erweckt werden; sprich erneut aktiviert
werden.
Damit der Roboter-Arm überhaupt den Druck
von der Seite ausübt, müssen die Fachleute
der NASA in die Trickkiste greifen.
Denn seine eingebauten Sicherheitsparameter
lassen diese Aktion eigentlich gar nicht zu.
Dazu der NASA-Ingenieur Ashitey Trebi-Ollennu:
“Wir werden den Arm anweisen, über seine
vorgesehenen Parameter hinaus zu agieren.
Er kann aber nicht so auf den Marsmaulwurf
drücken, wie es ein Mensch könnte.
Es wäre einfacher, wenn er es könnte, aber
das ist einfach nicht der Arm, den wir haben."
FALLS auch dieser Plan nicht aufgehen sollte,
werden die Wissenschaftlerinnen und Wissenschaftler
den Mars-Bohrer aber nicht ohne Weiteres aufgeben.
Möglicherweise ließe er sich nämlich auch
“retten”; indem der Krater aufgefüllt
würde.
Dazu könnte die Roboterarm-Schaufel Oberflächenmaterial
in das Loch kratzen.
Wie sah der mars eigentlich früher aus?
anklicken, anschauen und astro comics tv abonnieren.
Bis dann, bleibt dran!